of the rules committee Thursday
March fourteenth is hereby
called the war good morning
learn all advise and audio
and video recordings being
made of today's proceedings
is also being told --
madam secretary please call
the roll Cooley here Cunningham
Carillo Lara Grayson
Kamlager-Dove here Maienschein
Mathis at perks over
from us here that's yeah
Wicks California we have a
quorum consent agenda is our
motion like a seven general
mover Mysteron most
seconded by ms sounding good
-- many center please call
the roll Cooley Cooley
aye Cunningham Carillo
Carillo aye flora for a reason
three some I Kamlager-Dove
Kamlager-Dove five Maienschein
five Maienschein aye Mathis
folks Silva quirk Silva aye
rumors from us I request three
of us I works works online
Los is past and future
business thank you very much